Nous sommes au 15ème siècle,
pendant la guerre de 100 ans.
La moitié du territoire français
est sous domination anglaise.
Charles VI, dit «Le roi Fol»
est schizophrène.
Il souffre de démence
et danse de façon obscène
en prétendant s'appeler Georges.
Je trouve pas ça obscène
personnellement.
Oui mais
Charles VI a un fils
qui s'appelle Charles VII.
Les anglais petits filous
profitent de la folie du roi
pour lui faire signer un papier
disant que son fils c'est un bâtard.
Un bâtard ne peut pas être roi.
Mon fils
est un
bâ...tard.
Signé: George.
No... No,no.
vous vous appelez Charles.
Qui?
Laissez un blanc,
on va finir.
Comment ça se danse
votre danse?
Comme ça!
Le fils du roi de France
se retrouve littéralement clodo.
Il est complètement triste et perdu.
Je suis triste et perdu. (Voix bizarre)
Mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette voix?
C'est quand je ressens
une vive émotion.
Ok,
au temps pour moi.
C'est là que Jeanne débarque!
Je suis Jeanne d'Arc,
la pucelle d'Orléans
et je viens prêter main forte
à l'héritier légitime du roi de France
pour bouter les anglais
hors de nos frontières
et lui rendre son trône
parce que trois voix
m'ont parlé dans ma tête.
Faudra revenir jeudi.
... parce que 3 voix
m'ont parlé dans ma tête!
Nous sommes les conseillers du roi.
Nous demandons des preuves.
Comment peux-tu prouver
que tu as bien entendu les voix
que tu dis que tu as entendues?
Hein ?
Et comment pouvez-vous
prouver le contraire?
Oh! Cette répartie était ahurissante!
Bon, admettons.
Et pour le deuxième truc que tu dis.
Rapport à la virginité, tout ça.
Quoi?
Même pas un petit bisou?
Rien de rien?
-Rien de rien, je le jure.
Bon, c'est bien mais je demande
quand même un avis médical.
Qui est gynécologue ici?
Moi! Moi! Moi!Moi! Moi! Moi!
Moi! Moi! Moi!
Assez !
C'est à moi que revient cette tâche,
je suis le roi!
Oh, mais ça va on sait.
- Toujours pareil, toujours lui.
Ouais mais juste c'est pas poli cette histoire,
moi je viens,
j'emprunte un cheval, tout ça,
je voulais vous aider
à ne plus manger des racines
et au lieu d'être contents
vous voulez me gynecoliser?
Je sais que vous avez pris des habitudes
de clochard, mais y'a des limites.
Et c'est en remettant
tout le monde bien à sa place
que Jeanne s'attire le respect
et la confiance du roi.
Elle remporte bon nombre de batailles,
au nom du fils du roi.
Et c'est ainsi que se termine
très très très bien,
l'histoire de Charles VII,
roi de France.
Je suis content!
Quant à Jeanne,
le roi la remercia
en ne l'aidant pas du tout,
au moment où elle est capturée
par les anglais et brulée vive à Rouen.
Sérieusement? A Rouen?
En tout cas d'après des chaussettes.